[Musique]
bonjour pas un journal télévisé depuis
quelques semaines dans lequel on entende
parler de l' affaire clearstream mais
clearstream c'est quoi une lessiveuse
mystérieuse d'argent sale la clé de bien
des affaires de narco trafic de trafic
d'armes
et ou de mondialisation et de
licenciement notre invité aujourd'hui et
denis robert journaliste écrivain
artiste auteur il ya dix ans d'une
enquête sur clearstream dire stream
c'est une chambre de compensation
financière basée au luxembourg qui était
alors inconnu du grand public et dont il
dénonçait les agissements troubles
aujourd'hui tout le monde en france
connait clearstream c'est devenu
évidemment synonyme de scandale d'état
dix ans de bataille judiciaire 60 pouces
et des centaines des huissiers à votre
porte de ce les inimitiés dans le monde
politique tout de même il en reste est
également parmi vos nos confrères le
milieu de la presse et puis un éclair et
puis la nuit après dix ans voilà le 3
février 2011 c'est encore tout frais
tout récent d'accord de cassation vous
planchez définitivement et reconnaît
dans votre travail votre travail alors
du journaliste et d'enquêteurs
[Musique]
il ya internet quoi voilà ils peuvent
rien contre internet
encore ils peuvent rien surnom mais ils
pourront rien ils peuvent faire toutes
les lois qui volent jeudi rend les
emmerdes quoi il ils n'y arriveront pas
moi quand j'ai vu françois hollande au
bourget s'attaque à la finance en train
etc je crois que t'as pas mal mais je
sentais gros coup de bluff en plus c'est
là dessus qu'ils gagnent beaucoup les
élections parce qu'en face ils avaient
un sarkozy sur l'histoire des banques il
était minable pour l'heure on en a rien
à [__] de ce qu'ils sont des paradis
c'est du discours c'était une manière de
d'être au pouvoir s'il avait vraiment
une volonté politique forte de lutter
contre les paradis fiscaux ils avaient
ils ont toute latitude pour le faire
d'un point de vue économique c'est une
catastrophe au niveau de la presse
papier ça c'est évident les ventes du
poids en baisse de 16% ou d'un et
trimestre 7 de loeb son décès de 14 et
l'express qui a fait nos relances à
17,10 libération dans une situation
catastrophique
est ce que le fait que les journalistes
ne présente pas le chiffre correctement
ou d'une façon enjouée mon jeu 2
28 points de capture du journaliste ou
un défaut d'information mais bien sûr
fadel
notre question quand il ya la réponse
que la presse financière est sans doute
la presse la plus inféodé et qu'ils
soient aux banques et aux égout fi ainsi
le journalisme financiers
j'ai peut-être comment dire notre
lapidaire dans mon propos mais n'existe
pas on voit bien que derrière il des
groupes de pression des groupes de
presse et c' est qu' on est d'une
manière générale bombardé d'un 10 de
chiffre de bourse et/ou qui sont
complètement falsifiés il ya un espèce
de grand mensonge autour de tout ça et
je crois pas au concours je crois pas
tout ça mais je sais très bien que ces
journaux sont payés par par arnaud par
pino par balles par l'est et par les
banques est qu'il ya des annonceurs et
qui a tout ça est que et qu'on peut pas
déplaire quoi et je les vues avec
clearstream c'était le summum que vous
vous êtes bombardé de procès et in fine
et même si vous gagnez vous perdez quoi
les éditeurs de presse une journaliste
et les antes tellement peur maintenant
des mêmes plus de perdre des procès mais
ils ont peur des procès parce que les
procédures qui gère s'assure qu'ils
étaient évidemment il ya une autocensure
il ya une censure et ça c'est dramatique
la ferc à vizag pour parler d'elle a
montré que les criquets quant à une
volonté journalistique forte tu arrives
à renverser des pouvoirs on voudrait
votre avis sur la sphère snowdon
[Musique]
oui
je trouve incroyable que la france fut
de ne pas nous donne pas l'asie serait
tu t'étais justice mais là on est dans
la géopolitique on est dans la
realpolitik et n'est donc voilà on
s'attaque pas impunément aux états unis
quoi ces gens font de la politique mais
ils font pas la politique donc qui n'ont
aucun courage ils ont aucune et ils sont
en train de vendre leur âme ils ont
perdu ils sont en train de perdre
perdent toutes les batailles il ya
internet quoi voilà ils peuvent rien
contre internet
encore une preuve rien surnom me pour
rien qu'ils peuvent faire toutes les
lois qu'ils veulent je dire en lisant
merde quoi ils n'y arriveront pas
[Musique]
cette crise nous c'est juste un an son
programme particulier d'un plan plus
général on voit ça s'appelait s'inscrit
d'ailleurs dans le poids lourd une
expédition
ni les russes ni les chinois n'ont pas
envie que l'onu se transforme en une
machine à donner les bons et des mauvais
points de gouvernance
[Musique]